bonsoir nous sommes lundi un 1er février
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour votre actualité locale
entouré de nos invités mais aussi des
journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite les titres de cette édition
david douillet prend la tête de la
formation les républicains dans les
yvelines ce week-end les militants ont
désigné leurs représentants dans les
différentes fédérations de france
l'ancien judoka succède à valérie
pécresse jusqu'au 5 février
l'association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique organise la
semaine du microcrédit un moyen d'aider
les entrepreneurs à se créer leurs
propres emplois que nous en parler en
plateau isabelle treguer délégué
territorial de l'adie dans les yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine et enfin françois
rollin sociétaire des grosses têtes sur
rtl remontent sur scène c'est avec son
emblématique costume du professeur
rollin de la série palace qu'il règle
ses comptes avec la bien-pensance lui
qui a aussi collaboré à l'écriture des
spectacles d'arnaud tsamère était à bois
d'arcy samedi dernier circulez en
intérim dans les yvelines s'est à
présent autorisé à partir d'aujourd'hui
la circulation inter files des deux ou
trois roues motorisés sera expérimentée
pendant quatre ans dans les huit
départements d'île de france ainsi que
dans les bouches-du-rhône la gironde et
le rhône ces départements ont été
choisis en raison de leurs mauvaises
conditions de circulation dans ces
départements
une forme sécurisée de circulation inter
files sera autorisé bien qu'elle reste
interdite partout ailleurs
l'expérimentation pourra être prolongé
pour une année supplémentaire
elle pourra aussi être suspendus à tout
moment si trop d'accidents sont
constatés si dans son ensemble elle se
révèle concluante la circulation inter
files pourra être étendu à l'ensemble du
territoire français et vous justement
que pensez vous de cette mesure c'est ce
que nous vous avons demandé aujourd'hui
regardé home où ça me dérange pas plus
que ça
vu qu'ils le font déjà je suis habitué
on va dire déjà les actions avec les
assurances si ça se passe mieux ce
serait pas mal mais je trouve pas ça
légal du tout je trouve que
les voitures en leur voix et on verrait
pas ça en suisse et par par exemple donc
ici ça favorise l'e jean-alain
discipline n'est pas besoin d'une loi
puisque ça déjà cédé l'actuel tous les
moteurs sont périphériques le fond mais
je trouve que ça fluidifie le trafic à
partir du moment où il roule pas comme
des fous bien entendu toute façon la
moto c'est dangereux donc la loi par
elle même elle n'est pas plus dangereuse
qu on fait économie à présent cette
semaine l'a dit l'association pour le
droit à l'initiative économique
lens la semaine du microcrédit je vous
le disais en titre pour nous en parler
isabelle treillières délégué territorial
de ladite dans les yvelines et dans
notre scène bon soir soit merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors
l'association je le rappelle est née en
1989 le but était d'adapter à la france
le principe du microcrédit mécanisme
financier qui a largement fait ses
preuves dans les pays du tiers-monde en
asie en afrique et en amérique latine
mais tout n'est pas encore très connue
finalement aux français ce qu'ils
avaient très bien vous pouvez nous
rappeler le principe du microcrédit
qu'est ce que fait et à qui s'adresse
mais effectivement donc le microcrédit
c'est un petit crédit comme son nom l
indique il s'adresse à des personnes qui
veulent mon se mettre à leur compte
monter une petite entreprise et qui
n'ont pas accès aux prêts bancaires
donc en 1989 maria nowak s'est inspiré
de ce qui se faisait ailleurs pour
pouvoir proposer en france ce système de
financement qui permet à des personnes
en situation un peu compliquée de
pouvoir quand même démarrer leur
entreprise et de créer leur emploi
alors quand on parle de microcrédit
c'est moins de 15000 euros ça c'est
moins de 10000 euros moins dix mille
euros et juste assez jusqu'à 10000 euros
les exactions continuent leur auxquels
sont un peu les conditions pour
l'obtenir six aides et prêts personnels
et des prêts professionnels alors
l'activité principale de la dce et déjà
le microcrédit pour se mettre à son
compte pour ouvrir son entreprise donc
c'est ce microcrédit est limitée à dix
mille euros pour les personnes qui n'ont
pas accès aux prêts bancaires
donc c'est vraiment un relais pour leur
permettre de commencer et de démarrer
leur activité ou même dans les cinq
premières années de l'entreprise de
pouvoir venir en aide pour développer
l'entreprise
donc pour pouvoir financer une personne
on va s'assurer effectivement qu'elle
est déjà en adéquation par rapport à son
projet on va l'aider
avancer son projet avec nos partenaires
tous les partenaires de la création
et puis on va aussi l'aider en regardant
ses comptes pour voir si on ne va pas la
mettre en difficulté au contraire
pouvoir l'aider à monter son entreprise
alors il ya d'autres sensations
partenaires notamment france actifs bg
mines bim d'autres partenaires on doit
s'adresser à eux c'est justement vous
bénéficiez de microcrédit alors pour la
partie financement cela-dit mais par
contre pour pouvoir monter son projet
effectivement c'est intéressant d'aller
voir déjà la chambre de commerce si ce
sont des activités de vente la chambre
des métiers pour les artisans et pour
pouvoir se renseigner ensuite
effectivement on est en relation avec
d'autres partenaires la bg aux yvelines
pour pouvoir effectivement avancé sur un
prévisionnel d'activité met les premiers
chiffres sur l'activité
et puis avec yveline actifs par exemple
si la personne a accès aux prêts
bancaires et veut un prêt d'honneur à
côté alors depuis 1989 plus de 90000 je
crois pas non plus de 93 des entreprises
ont été créées
le microcrédit lui aussi évolué cette
année donc le décret du 14 janvier à
2016 a modifié les conditions d'octroi
du microcrédit alors il ya plusieurs
choses qui sont évoluent et sur les
conditions d'attribution et aussi les
places alors la première chose
effectivement sur les plafonds l'ours
est intéressant d'abord sur une deuxième
partie de microcrédit c'est selon ceux
qui sont destinés à des personnes qui
veulent se maintenir dans l'emploi
salarié ou qui sont en recherche très
active un pas salarié et qui par exemple
dans les yvelines ont une problématique
de mobilité
ils ont besoin de fonds pour pouvoir
acheter un véhicule jusqu'à présent on
était limitée à 3000 euros là avec ce
qu'un 5000 euros elles ont la
possibilité d'acheter un véhicule qui va
qui serait peut-être un peu mieux qui
leur permettra de mieux répondre à leurs
besoins
sur la partie microcrédit professionnel
donc ce dont je parlais au départ là
pour l'instant pas de changement on est
en réflexion sur le sujet ça va être
l'objet de travaux cours du premier
semestre pour savoir de quelle manière
vont évoluer les plafonds mais
aujourd'hui le plafond c'est toujours
dix mille euros
alors jusqu'alors les entreprises ne
pouvaient se voir octroyer donc ce prêt
que pendant les cinq premières années
sur leur création est désormais celles
qui ont déjà bénéficié d'un microcrédit
peuvent en obtenir d'eux
nouveau durant les sept années suivantes
ça alors pendant 75 ans plus deux ans en
fait on se rend compte effectivement au
bout de cinq ans certains chefs
d'entreprise n'ont toujours pas accès à
un prêt bancaire nous sollicitent pour
exemple pour un développement
on peut leur venir en aide toujours dans
les limites de notre plafond mais ça
peut être aussi une possibilité pour
nous de l'est de les soutenir davantage
alors j'ai quelques données à devant moi
la dernière le réseau apporte et donc
ses encours de prêts garantis à 350
millions d'euros contre 236 millions
d'euros fin 2014
au sein de l'as dit le nombre de projets
financés a aussi progressé de 10% en
est-ce que c'est finalement un bon signe
ou est-ce que cela témoigne justement la
difficulté de trouver un travail pour
les personnes qui qui vous font vous
voir alors c'est d'abord un bon signe
d'activité d'activité en fait de
personnes qui au delà de chercher un
emploi salarié vont se prendre en main
et vont pouvoir avancer se mettre à leur
compte
donc ça ce sont en fait des petites
activités locales qui sont très
importantes dans tissu économique local
donc pour ça c'est effectivement un
point très positif et c'est intéressant
que l'adie puisse les aider à se lancer
il ya également effectivement la lutte
contre le chômage qui est un autre point
c'est que finalement ces personnes n'ont
pas trouvé d'emploi salarié et vont se
tourner vers une autre solution que la
création d'entreprise peut être une
alternative vraiment intéressante pour
certaines personnes et à condition
d'être accompagné pour pouvoir se lancer
en toute sécurité et pouvoir développer
son entreprise
est-ce que c'est pas difficile de
pousser un peu les gens à créer leur
entreprise sachant qu'il ya beaucoup
voilà d'éléments qui montrent qu'en
france c'est pas évident forcément de
pouvoir la montée que ce soit elle soit
pérenne a également alors ça
effectivement c'est très important pour
la dit de ne pas laisser les
entrepreneurs seul de continuer à les
accompagner donc on a en fait une double
activité qui est le financement d'une
part et
l'autre partie c'est l'accompagnement
qui va avec ce financement pour les
aider à démarrer en sécurité et puis a
trouvé la pérennisation de leur
entreprise c'est effectivement
l'objectif c'est qu'ils puissent
développer leur entreprise qu'ils
puissent tirer un revenu qui va leur
permettre de vivre de leur activité
alors cette semaine il ya justement
d'associatifs organisé pour se faire
encore plus voilà connaître comment ça
se passe et ce qui en a certaines qui
sont les huiles eh oui bien sûr chaque
année à cette période là dit lance la
semaine du microcrédit pour être au plus
près des personnes qui peuvent être
intéressés et puis pour augmenter un peu
la visibilité et donc cette année dans
les yvelines on a trois événements
demain matin à notre agence à poissy
ombre soit vraiment tout le public qui
est intéressé par la création
d'entreprise et qui veut une première
information de me soir avec le rotary
club de versailles on a un événement qui
va récompenser dix sept entrepreneurs
soutenus par l'adie et qui ont bien
réussi donc c'est aussi un événement
important puisqu'on à d'autres
organismes d'autres associations qui
nous soutiennent et mercredi matin enfin
dans le sud des yvelines
on sera à montigny le bretonneux
la maison de l'entreprise pour les
informer sur le démarrage d'une activité
en micro entreprise
alors justement est ce que dans les
yvelines vous constaté depuis la
création 89 il ya peut-être plus de gens
qui font appel au microcrédit comment se
situe un petit peu les entrepreneurs
gestion son territoire alors c'est en
progression surtout l'année dernière on
a été plus visible
on a travaillé davantage aussi avec nos
partenaires
parmi les partenaires on a aussi pôle
emploi c'est important effectivement de
pouvoir travailler ensemble de pouvoir
détecter les personnes qui ont envie
créer leur entreprise mais qui ont
besoin d'accompagnement
donc on travaille cet aspect là avec
pôle emploi ça nous permet effectivement
d'être mieux connus ça nous permet aussi
de ne pas laisser les personnes isolées
face à leur projet et au contraire de
les accompagner
est ce que j'espère il y avait peut-être
un conseil à donner à des personnes qui
hésiteraient à venir vous voir qu'ils ne
savent pas encore parce que peut-être ça
peut prendre beaucoup de temps
alors je crois qu'il faut pas du tout
hésité à venir nous voir au contraire on
est là pour les accueillir pour donner
des premiers éléments de réponse
quand on fait un projet de création
d'entreprise on a besoin d'en parler
autour de soi il faut un peu challenge
et c'est à dire que il faut voir s'il y
dépasse déjà dans son entourage voire
auprès de professionnels donc au
contraire il faut pas hésiter à nous
solliciter pour avoir un premier avis
très bien merci beaucoup et isabelle
rivière alors voilà si vous voulez plus
d'informations peuvent vous rendre sur
le site de ladite www.adie.org l'adresse
va s'afficher en dessous de votre écran
et je le rappelle sur notre territoire
mercredi 3 février à 10 heures à la
maison de l'entreprise de saint quentin
12 avenue des prêts à montigny le
bretonneux
il y à une réunion d'information de 10h
à 12h qui s'intitule bien démarré son
activité en micro-entreprise merci
beaucoup aussi
et revenons sur ce qui s'est passé le
jeudi 28 janvier les habitués de la rn
10 ont une surprise on la découvre ont
totalement déserte
l'accès était fermé une partie de
l'après-midi au niveau de trappes la
cause une opération de déminage d'une
bombe anglaise de 500 kg datant de la
seconde guerre mondiale l'engin a été
découvert dans la rue casanova en fin
d'année 2015 dans le cadre de travaux
d'assainissement
le secteur a donc été totalement évacué
400 riverains ont dû quitter
or l'agent des trésors des mesures
nécessaires pour dominer qu'elle lepidi
directeur de cabinet du préfet des
yvelines
près de 200 personnes aujourd'hui
en comptant les services de la ville et
notamment la police municipale la police
nationale il l'ensemble des services de
l'état sont mobilisés voyez derrière moi
donc la coupure de delà de la rn 10 aux
fins de neutralisation de l'engin
puisque on était vraiment sur un péril
imminent et culture à présent c'est une
activité que l'on retrouve souvent sur
les quais de seine à paris ce week-end
la caricature s'est invitée à elancourt
le caricaturiste gribouille tout a pris
ses quartiers le temps d'un après midi à
la médiathèque 17 mar une animation
proposée par l'année médiathèque de
saint quentin en yvelines dans le cadre
de la thématique la bd dans tous ses
états l'occasion pour nous de rencontrer
cet artiste physionomiste regardez ce
reportage signé camille lambert d'un
coup de crayon il tient votre portrait
en seulement quelques minutes
gribouille tout s'est installé samedi 30
janvier à la médiathèque 17 mar
d'elancourt les visiteurs ont pu jouer
les modèles le temps d'un après midi un
peu méchant pas forcer le trait avec
tact et bonne humeur une recette que
gribouille tous appliquent depuis une
quinzaine d'années un amour de la
caricature qui a commencé dès l'enfance
en voyant des artistes dessinée sur les
bords de plage à saint malo aujourd'hui
il entretient une relation privilégiée
avec ses victimes visage ça touche
toujours un petit peu sur montreuil
les yeux la bouche mais j'ai déjà pu un
peu sur le nez un petit peu sur les yeux
sur le sourire et puis voilà on essaie
de faire un petit compositions souvent
c'est bah ça c'est moi je me reconnais
pas ça ressemble à ma mère ça ressemble
à mon père je raconte ça ressemble à
quelqu'un de ma famille moi je trouve
qu'il a bien bien comment on va dire ça
insisté sur le caractère un peu rock que
j'ai le style un peu un peu plus bohème
rock mes mails et les autres dames et
jeunes filles qu'il a à croquer c'était
plutôt soft pas trop violent je dirais
ou agressif mais c'est bien ça veut dire
que le monsieur il est aussi psychologue
et fin diplomate dans son dessin c'est
important derrière la vie d'artiste il
ya aussi la vie de famille gribouille
tout est venue accompagnée de sa fille
charlotte
du haut de ses 10 ans et dégaine ses
crayons aux côtés de son père la relève
est déjà assurée pour les ti-cats
présents ont voté ce week-end au sein du
parti les républicains les militants
désignés partout en france leurs
représentants dans les instances locales
dans les yvelines david douillet seul
candidat à la présidence devient le
nouveau chef de file du mouvement il
succède à valérie pécresse les détails
avec wilfrid richy david douillet 46 ans
nouveau patron de la fédération
yvelinoise l'est républicain ancien
ministre actuel député et conseiller
régional il succède à ce poste à valérie
pécresse élue présidente de l'île de
france sa priorité accroître le nombre
d'adhérents c'est aussi intéressant
voire plus intéressant c'est que toutes
les personnes de sensibilité de droite
du lichen ou alors on pourrait dire
qu'ils sont la méritocratie et puis
l'envi que le pays se sort de cette
ornière économique en termes de création
de richesse et bien puisse participer à
un débat qui nous permettra d'avoir les
meilleures solutions au poste de
secrétaire départemental devrait être
nommé pour épauler david douillet sophie
primas sénatrice cette élection interne
était surtout l'occasion de mettre en
marche le parti avant l'échéance
présidentielle et législatives de 2010
est lourde aux responsabilités parce que
lui c'est de loin le plus grand parti de
france
aujourd'hui structuré et remis en marche
depuis l'est depuis les mésaventures de
l'ump de l'époque et c'est exactement ce
qu'on va continuer à faire dans les
disciplines avec je l'espère un
accroissement des adhérents en attendant
2017 l'ancien judoka double champion
olympique va devoir repartir sur le
terrain pour la campagne de la
législative partielle dans la seconde
circonscription
les électeurs sont appelés aux urnes les
13 et 20 mars après la démission de
valérie pécresse
les républicains désigneront leur
candidat dans les prochains jours le
maire de vélizy est en bonne position
pour l'emporter et samedi matin se
déroulait le second conseil
d'installation de la nouvelle
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines les élus devaient choisir leurs
représentants au sein de différentes
commissions on retiendra deux choses
michel auger président de saint-quentin
siégera au sein de l'établissement
public d'aménagement de paris saclay le
pôle scientifique donc et que jean
michel fourgous deuxième vice-président
de saint-quentin daluis siéger au sein
de l'ue du conseil d'administration de
l'université évinoise lu vs cuche est
toujours à saint quentin en yvelines et
tensions restent fortes entre la
majorité de centre droit et son
opposition de gauche les élus de gauche
qui contestent leur absence des postes
de vice présidence ont décidé de déposer
un recours devant le conseil
administratif ils veulent des précisions
sur les modalités de désignation écouter
et sandrine grand bond pour les
socialistes puis grégory guéret astier
pour les républicains
on est clairement une période de
défiance dire que il ya une forme de
rupture de confiance qu'on a manifesté
par le fait qu'on n'a pas participé au
vote des présidents et vice-présidents
puisque on a été de fait exclus de
l'exécutif en tant que représentant les
villes de gauche
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya un malaise il
va falloir qu'on retrouve l'ailé
les liens de confiance qui existait qui
pour l'instant sont pas là donc nous
tous qui est paru au mois d'août
paraître un peu étrange ou en
contravention avec la loi on va demander
un éclaircissement de la visite
moi j'ai siégé avec mon équipe le 9
janvier dernier au conseil
d'installation et je viens tout juste de
ressort à recommander pour la première
fois de ma vie d'un du tribunal
administratif puisque la gauche conteste
l'élection du président et des vice
présidents des conseils communautaires
et de tous les organismes dans lequel on
va siéger
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
reçois un courrier du tribunal alors
s'ils voulaient vraiment faire partie de
l'exécutif je crois que c'est mal barré
excusez moi le terme la cérémonie
les cérémonies des voeux pardon se
termine vendredi dernier c'était au tour
du maire d'elancourt le républicain jean
michel fourgous en présence des
représentants de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines et des
communes avoisinantes des loups dans un
discours très marquée par le libéralisme
sont une nouvelle fois près la politique
du gouvernement et aux choix opérés pour
lutter contre le chômage sur le plan
local il a rappelé quelques uns des
projets qui seront portés au cours des
prochains mois sur sa ville ray aman
réaménagement de la zone des quatre
arbres enfouissement des lignes haute
tension préparation du chantier du
commissariat d'agglomération ou dans un
délai plus court
l'armement de la police municipale la
reconstruction du gymnase
lionel terray fait également partie des
priorités deuxième vice président de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge du
développement économique
jean michel fourgous a également rappelé
l'ouverture prochaine survie en coin
d'un incubateur un lieu d'échangé pour
les porteurs de projet et nous
accueillons sephora namani bonsoir assez
fou rappelant ses ovocytes pouvez nous
présenter le portrait de françois rollin
à l'occasion de son passage samedi soir
à la grange de la tramblais de bois
d'arcy
il remontait sur scène avec son
emblématique professeur rollin oui tout
à fait depuis le 29 janvier dernier
françois rollin a souhaité faire revivre
au théâtre à paris en tournée dans toute
la france un personnage qui lui est cher
ce fameux professeur rollin créé dans
les années 2000 nous sommes allé lui
demander quel rapport il entretenait
justement avec son personnage
le professeur rollin c'est ce double qui
m'accompagne depuis maintenant quelques
années on ne dit pas le nombre assez
comme pour l'âge des dames ont dit pas
au delà d'eux
place d'un temps françois hollande n'est
pas que le professeur le professeur et
est un personnage un peu à part mais
fraternellement liam le public
elle aime bien ce personnage et puis
c'est un il est porteur d'une façon
particulière de s'exprimer donc
régulièrement à la radio la télévision
ou sur les planches
sa présence s'impose d'elle-même
je réponde le réservoir et le raisin
blanc ont tous les deux été baptisé par
les daltoniens mais pas par les mêmes
daltonien en effet chacun de nous en
rendre compte le réservoir mais pas noir
et blanc est pas blanc le président noir
et violet foncé et le raisin blanc est
fait il y en a autant de différence
entre le vert et le blanc qu'il y en a
entre la normandie et la poésie c'est
drôlement bien l'observer et quelques
lignes plus loin
saint macary ajoute en revanche entre le
noir et le violet foncé j'avoue
humblement que moi même plus le voit pas
toujours très bien la différence
fin de citation françois rolland on
connaît bien sûr en tant qu'humoriste
mais il a différentes facettes il est
aussi acteur journaliste et scénariste
oui tout à fait diplômé de l'essec alors
comprenez l'école supérieure des
sciences économiques et commerciales
il démarre au journal le monde puis
enchaîne les chroniques dans différentes
revues avant d'intégrer la fameuse série
télévisée palace en 1988 qui vraiment le
fait connaître au grand public aux côtés
de françois morel jean michel ribes
wolinski jean marie gourio des guignols
et j'en passe c'est d'ailleurs à cette
époque qu'il se forge compagnie d'un
personnage du professeur rollin
l'accueil va multiplier les apparitions
sur scène et sur le petit écran tout à
fait alors on a pu l'entendre également
à la radio dans des émissions
humoristiques sur france inter aux robes
de ou france culture il était d'ailleurs
encore jusqu'à l'année dernière dans la
matinale de patrick cohen pour une
chronique humoristique le mardi matin il
a multiplié les rôles aussi sur petit et
grand écran et s'est adonné à l'écriture
aussi bien l'écriture de ce spectacle de
publication avec mon dernier la parution
2015 les dictées mouffok du professeur
rollin est aussi ajoutons à cela une
activité de metteur en scène importante
on note le spectacle d'arnaud tsamère en
2005 et guy carrier le spectacle de guy
carlier en deux
11 celui de jean marie bigard en 2013 et
très récemment celui de vincent de dien
donc une carrière assez longue et plutôt
diversifiée il a donc eu envie de
retrouver les planches depuis 2015 c'est
bien ça oui tout à fait un retour aux
sources avec son personnage de
prédilection à l'exercice à l'exercice
qu'il considère comme étant le plus
exigeant de tous pour moi le travail au
théâtre c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
exigeant de plus difficile et en même
temps c'est nécessaire parce que c'est
le coeur de métier
voilà c'est sûr que dans les jours de
paresse je me dispenserait bien de
monter sur scène
c'est tellement dans le dans la
mythologie du de l'artiste le théâtre
qu' il n'y a pas moyen de ne pas y aller
alors dans ce spectacle il est toujours
question d' absurde son domaine préféré
on évoque des questions métaphysiques
bien sûr autour de la couleur du raisin
ou du goût du paprika toujours cette
volonté de partager imaginaire drôlerie
fantaisie et légèreté mais cette fois ci
le professeur rollin se rebiffe vraiment
en dénonçant ce qu'il appelle la
dictature de la bien bon sens il évoque
des questions plus sérieuses sociétales
et politiques tels que l'immigration le
racisme ou encore la religion
un nouveau message que je fais passer
maintenant est qui et qui pourrait se
résumer ainsi un artiste surtout après
le 7 janvier et le 13 novembre peut
difficilement ne pas se préoccuper ne
pas aborder les problèmes de la société
dans laquelle il vit
voilà c'est pas normalement mon truc je
suis pas chanceux n'y ai je pas
chroniqueur politique c'est pas je vous
parle est donc comme un poisson dans
l'eau mais je sens bien que maintenant
il y aurait comme une forme de lâcheté
et de démission à ne pas prendre en
compte du tout ces phénomènes
épouvantable un spectacle que vous
pourrez retrouver en tournée dans toute
la france jusqu'à l'été prochain merci
beaucoup à sephora on vous retrouve
mercredi pour une validation de kiosques
magazine la culture elle est tout autre
sujet à présent c'était il ya soixante
deux ans le 1er février 1954
les températures sont glaciales et
l'abbé pierre lance son appel à la radio
rtl
au secours des couches dehors un appel
qui fera exploser les dons ce qu'il
appellera lui-même l'insurrection de la
bonté chez malgré des températures
largement plus chaudes
cet hiver la requête de l'abbé pierre
reste toujours d'actualité
on écoutait les précisions de christophe
robert délégué général de la fondation
abbé pierre
là où il ya des éléments qui restent
similaires à ce qu'on a connu en 54
c'est qu'il ya encore des gens qui
jusqu'à la rue qui meurent à la rue on a
encore des gens qui vivent bidonvilles
ont pensé que c'est bidon vide avait
disparu du paysage de la france ils sont
réapparus aux portes de nos grandes
villes laissant des percées dans des
conditions de vie totalement indigne les
logements pour les personnes qui ont la
chance d'avoir un logement
on va vers une amélioration nette
d'année en année de décennie en décennie
si on prend la question par exemple du
sans abrisme le fait de vivre à la rue
ces chiffres ont augmenté de façon
catastrophique entre 2001 et 2012
le chiffre est monté à 50 %
d'augmentation tous les personnes sans
domicile fixe et enferme ce journal avec
une page de sport le plaisir on belle
club n'en finit plus de gagner les ivy
notre infligé une véritable correction à
val de seine ce dimanche
le score est sans appel et 41 à 30 leur
billon est désormais de 11 victoires en
12 matches disputés conséquence plaisir
reste leader de prénationale
regardez le reportage vidéo on n'aurait
plus le plaisir handball club les ivy
loi se sont imposé une nouvelle fois à
domicile leur victime du jour
val-de-seine largement dominateurs les
plaisirs ont corrigé leurs adversaires
ce camp final 41 30 bacon s'ils ne
s'étaient pas de prendre le match à la
légère
on a bien faire on a eu 1 on a eu un peu
peur au mieux du match con sen venu à
égalité mais bon là on a remis les
choses au clair dès mi temps donc
c'était bien faire de dégâts l'homme du
match le gardien jean marc bérelles lord
valeur de 41 ans a sorti une trentaine
d'arrêt pendant la rencontre
on l'a pris 38 donc j'ai pas plus
satisfait que ça de mon match avec cette
victoire plaisir est premier du
championnat de prénationale labonté
l'objectif fixé cette saison par le club
est donc envisageable
on va parler de montée tout de suite on
va attendre on va prendre les matches
les uns après les autres il ya paris
sport club qui suit le rythme c'est une
très très belle équipe
voilà il ya versac est une belle équipe
via métro voilà il ya la poule est très
costaud donc voilà tous les matches vont
être super important on prend vraiment
personne à la légère et on verra on fera
les comptes au mois de juin en espérant
que cette fois ça par pur plaisir
prochain match pour plaisir ce dimanche
7 février contre evry une équipe qui
lutte pour le maintien c'est la fin de
cette émission merci nous avoir suivis
tout de suite vous avez rendez vous avec
michael me d'euros pour le cetud sports
mercredi 3 février vous pourrez regarder
dans son édition spéciale avec en invité
le préfet des yvelines serge borvon qui
sera en direct je vous retrouve demain
pour une nouvelle édition du journal je
souhaite une très bonne soirée